Bonjour tout le monde, bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, j'essaie un concept un peu nouveau, c'est-à-dire que je suis en
stream,
donc pour ceux qui ne le savent pas, je fais des streams sur la plateforme
Twitch
et je publie des vidéos de gaming en parlant dans un français lentement.
Toutes ces vidéos sont disponibles sur ma chaîne secondaire
et aujourd'hui, en fait, j'avais envie d'essayer quelque chose.
C'est de parler en direct d'un sujet et voir échanger avec les personnes qui
sont sur le chat.
Donc pour le moment, il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde,
mais je pense qu'au fur et à mesure, ça pourrait être intéressant
de discuter de sujets en live comme ça pour faire des podcasts
et voilà, pour que ce soit plus intéressant pour tout le monde.
Donc on est partis pour une vingtaine de minutes, 20-30 minutes.
Je pense qu'on va voir combien de temps ça prend.
Et aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de parler pour ce premier test,
j'avais envie de parler de Pokémon.
Donc ça, c'est une carte Pokémon.
Et en fait, sur le chat, il y a Dipsun.
Et Dipsun, c'est mon frère qui stream aussi et qui aime beaucoup Pokémon.
Et du coup, parfois, avec Dipsun, on ouvre des cartes Pokémon.
C'est-à-dire qu'on achète des paquets, enfin, lui, principalement, achète des
paquets.
Et on ouvre les cartes en stream pour essayer d'avoir des cartes rares.
Et en fait, aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de discuter de cet aspect des cartes
Pokémon,
qui est la rareté et les prix que peuvent atteindre les cartes Pokémon.
Donc là, ça, c'est une carte que j'ai trouvé dans un paquet.
Et en fait, cette carte, elle vaut environ 100 euros.
Donc c'est quand même une somme.
On voit que, en fait, on la fait grader, c'est-à-dire que le cadre que vous
voyez autour,
c'est une entreprise qui permet de donner une note à la qualité de votre carte,
de votre carte, pardon.
Et après, grâce à cette note, votre carte va prendre plus ou moins de valeur.
Et du coup, forcément, avec cette popularité des cartes Pokémon,
il y a de plus en plus de monde, de personnes qui font de la spéculation.
Speculer, c'est acheter quelque chose pour espérer le revendre plus cher.
Il y a des gens qui spéculent sur des sneakers, sur des places de concerts.
Maintenant, il y a plein de choses sur lesquelles on spécule.
Et c'est le cas aussi des cartes Pokémon.
Donc la question aujourd'hui, c'est, en fait, c'est...
À la base, Pokémon, c'est un jeu pour enfants, et à la base, ce sont des petites
cartes en carton.
Et pourtant, ça atteint des niveaux records.
Là, c'est un peu plus bas qu'avant, mais en même temps, il y avait les
influenceurs américains
comme Logan Paul, par exemple, qui achetaient beaucoup de cartes Pokémon et
on voyait des cartes
des dracaufeux à 10 000 euros, par exemple, ou même d'autres cartes encore
plus chères.
Je sais plus, Dipsun, c'est quoi le record.
Mais voilà, des sommes d'argent énormes pour des cartes Pokémon.
Bien évidemment, il y a un aspect collectionneur, ou des Pikachu à 5,5 millions
de dollars, ouais.
Et il y avait aussi des cartes Magic, par exemple, c'est un autre jeu de
cartes
qui avait fait des cartes "Seigneur des anneaux", et il y avait un anneau
unique,
une carte unique dans le monde.
Et il me semble que c'est le rappeur Post Malone qui avait acheté cette carte
à la personne qu'il avait trouvée pour 2 millions de dollars et quelques...
En millions de dollars. C'est-à-dire, une somme d'argent que la plupart des gens
ne gagnent
même pas en une seule vie, et maintenant, on dépense cet argent, enfin ces
personnes-là,
dépensent cet argent pour acheter une carte.
L'idée, c'est pas de dire c'est mal ou c'est bien, c'est plus de discuter un peu
de ce
phénomène, de cette évolution qu'ont eu les cartes Pokémon, parce que, d'un côté
en fait,
il y a vraiment un aspect collectionneur, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des séries de
cartes Pokémon,
et si vous êtes un collectionneur comme Dipsun dans le chat,
vous avez envie en fait d'avoir toute la série.
Enfin, Dipsun, tu en parleras mieux, mais voilà, il y a quand même cet aspect
collectionneur.
Moi, je trouve ça cool pour la collection.
Oui, voilà, et quand nous, quand on était petits, la première série Pokémon,
il y avait 151 Pokémon, et l'objectif, c'était d'avoir tous les Pokémon,
comme dans le jeu vidéo. Oui, il avait racheté à un canadien 1,8 million, il me
semble,
mais l'histoire était belle car la personne qu'il avait eu faisait un boulot
manuel et
n'était pas spécialement riche. Ok. Donc la personne qui avait trouvé la carte
unique,
Seigneur des anneaux, c'était un peu comme s'il avait gagné au loto finalement,
parce qu'il n'avait pas vraiment de gros moyens, et il avait gagné la carte
unique,
parce qu'après, du coup, vous avez des personnes comme Logan Paul ou des
personnes qui ont beaucoup
d'argent qui vont affiter un maximum de cartes pour essayer de trouver les plus
rares pour spéculer.
Et en fait, du coup, il y a un peu ce, je trouve qu'il y a un peu cette limite
qui est fine entre
de la collection pure et dure et de la collection, de la collection pure et dure
et de la spéculation
pure et dure. Ce que je veux dire, j'ai entendu une alerte, mais je vois rien à
l'écran. Ce que
je veux dire, c'est que par exemple, cette carte, elle vaut 100 euros. Et en
fait, j'ai d'autres cartes,
et par exemple, j'ai celle-ci. Cette carte, elle vaut 100 euros parce qu'en
fait, ils avaient fait
une impression un peu particulière où vous voyez en reflet des Master Balls,
donc un objet rare de
Pokémon, enfin, rare. Et ce qui fait que cette carte est spéciale et qu'elle
coûte plus cher
qu'un Salamèche, donc ce Pokémon normal. Oui, et le parallèle au gambling est
totalement palpable,
car c'est totalement ça. Et même en boutique, maintenant, quand des gens
ouvrent, la plupart
des gens demandent le prix directement. Exactement. Et moi, comme je n'y connais
rien, quand je vais
ouvrir des cartes Pokémon avec Dipsun, ma première question, c'est, est-ce que
cette carte coûte
cher ? Et du coup, en fait, quand j'ouvre des cartes Pokémon, moi, je suis là
plus pour jouer au
casino que de collectionner des cartes Pokémon parce que la collection pure est
simple. Je pense
que ça se baserait plutôt sur juste de l'esthétique, c'est plus une question
d'esthétique. J'étais en
train de dire que ça, elle est un peu rare parce qu'il y a une impression
particulière, il y a des
reflets particuliers. Mais théoriquement, enfin, techniquement, je préfère ça
là, je la trouve
beaucoup plus jolie, c'est un peu difficile avec la lumière, mais en gros, c'est
un Mewtwo au-dessus
d'une ville et l'illustration est vraiment jolie. Et pourtant, ces deux cartes,
elles coûtent le
même prix, tout simplement parce qu'elles sont les gens, enfin, c'est une
question d'offre et de
demande, mais la rareté est équivalente. En sachant que, du coup, ces deux
cartes, elles sont notées,
je ne sais pas comment faire, elles sont notées dix, donc ça veut dire qu'elles
sont parfaites,
elles sont en état parfait. Et pareil, j'avais, j'ai que trois cartes et j'ai
celle-ci aussi,
une Pokémon, une Pikachu, le mec qui ne connaît rien, une Pikachu. Oui,
personnellement,
je collectionne certaines cartes, car elles sont réalisées par certains
illustrateurs,
ou alors simplement quand ce sont des Ectoplasma. D'ailleurs, si vous avez un
Ectoplasma, contactez-moi.
Donc Ectoplasma, c'est un Pokémon, en anglais, c'est Gengar. Et oui, les
collectionneurs Pokémon,
en général, ont un Pokémon favori et les collectionneurs essayent d'avoir toutes
les versions de
ces Pokémon. Et par exemple, il y a des cartes Pikachu et il y a des éditions
limitées Pikachu,
où Pikachu est en kimono, où Pikachu va à un festival, enfin, des cartes très
japonaises,
et qui pour le coup, je trouve que c'est vraiment, c'est vraiment un aspect
collection. Et du coup,
on n'est plus dans, enfin, il n'y a pas cette démarche de, ça coûte combien mais
plus. Est-ce
que c'est une carte jolie qui est rare, entre guillemets ? Au-delà du prix,
est-ce qu'elle est rare ? Pour,
pour finalement avoir tous les Pokémon que l'on veut qu'on apprécie. Moi, j'ai
que mon paquet
du CM1 et ma carte Bactolol. Donc du CM1, c'est l'école primaire en France. Donc
au CM1,
on a 8, 9 ans. Et du coup, nous, c'était très populaire quand on était petits.
Donc, dans la
cour d'école, on avait souvent des cartes Pokémon. Du coup, Juju a toujours son
paquet du CM1.
Je pense qu'elle ne valent pas grand-chose. Mais du coup, voilà. Et après, je
trouve que du
coup, ça amène une question. Cette idée du prix et de la spéculation, c'est qu'on
finit par un peu
définir la valeur des choses par leur prix seulement. C'est-à-dire que sur les
réseaux sociaux,
par exemple, on est arrivés à ne parler des cartes de Pokémon que pour leur
prix. On ne se posait
même plus la question de savoir si elles étaient belles ou pas. On se disait
juste "Ah, combien
écoute ? Ah, un million, je ne sais pas combien, un million de dollars." Et du
coup, ça n'a eu plus
vraiment d'intérêt en tant que telle. C'était vraiment juste de la spéculation.
Si, elles ont une
valeur sentimentale. Ce qui nous intéresse, c'est la valeur monétaire. Mais du
coup, voilà, je
trouve qu'il y a assez un peu ce gap entre l'aspect pure collection et ce
pourquoi les cartes
Pokémon ont été connues. Enfin, pourquoi il y a ce pic, notamment pendant le
confinement,
il me semble, où les cartes Pokémon ont pris énormément de valeur et finalement
on ne parlait
plus que de ça comme de quelque chose qui coûte hyper cher comme d'un casino
finalement. Et vous
avez même maintenant les personnes qui parlent de finance qui disent "Ah ben,
est-ce que ça vaut le
coup d'investir dans des cartes Pokémon ?" Toutes ces questions, je pense que
ce n'est pas des
questions qui sont vraiment nouvelles. Il y avait déjà ça avec les œuvres d'art.
Parfois, vous
voyez des œuvres d'art où vous dites "Bah, c'est moche et pourtant ça coûte
énormément d'argent."
Et en fait, il y a un côté business qui est totalement pas décorrélé mais qui
n'est pas
vraiment lié directement avec l'œuvre en elle-même. Certaines écoles commencent
à interdire les
cartes car trop de problèmes et les enfants se retrouvent avec des cartes
improbables ou
se font arnaquer. Oui, mais ça, le prix de l'œuvre, ça va être plus lié à la
cote de l'artiste mais
du coup, finalement, l'artiste, ça devient un businessman. Ça peut être appliqué
à n'importe
quelle forme d'art. La musique, par exemple, vous avez des artistes qui vont
essayer de faire une
musique qui soit le plus commercial possible avant d'essayer d'avoir une
démarche purement
artistique. Et ce n'est pas forcément mal ou bien mais c'est juste que, du coup,
ces questions,
elles arrivent aussi avec les cartes Pokémon. Ou finalement, il y a des gens qui
s'intéressent
seulement en carte Pokémon pour la spéculation. Après, pour la question des
écoles où il y avait
des problèmes avec les cartes, moi je me souviens que nous, à notre âge aussi,
enfin quand on était
à l'école, ça arrivait qu'il y avait des problèmes en mode on se fait arnaquer
ou on se
fait voler nos cartes, etc. Mais là, c'est sûr que ça prend des proportions à
cause de la valeur
des cartes. C'est sûr que s'il y a un enfant de 7 ans qui ouvre une carte à 10
000 euros dans
la cours de son école, ça doit être difficile à acheter. Et du coup, mais par
exemple, alors si
je vous partage mon écran, par exemple, maintenant, du coup, vous avez des sites
comme "Card Market"
qui est un peu la référence pour l'achat et la revente de cartes. Mais en fait,
si on sélectionne
par exemple Pokémon, si, dites-vous, il y a même de la manipulation de marché.
Par exemple,
sur le jeu "L'Orcana", c'est le TCG, donc le Trading Card Game de Disney, où une
carte était
passée de 200 euros à plus de 1000 euros en une journée, car un groupe avait
acheté la
totalité des annonces pour faire exploser la cote. Ah ouais, mais ça en fait,
c'est comme, c'est
comme, c'est un autre jeu mais Dofus, en fait, quand vous avez des places de
marché comme ça,
des endroits où vous pouvez acheter des cartes, vous pouvez faire gonfler le
prix en achetant
toutes les offres pour que les offres seulement disponibles soient à les vôtres
et vous augmenter
le prix pour gagner directement de l'argent. Oui, ça devient de la manipulation
de marché. Et là,
par exemple, donc si je prends, par exemple, le Mewtwo, ah, pardon, je suis sur
webcam. Le Mewtwo
que je vous ai montré. Alors, je ne suis pas un pro, donc je vais essayer de
rechercher la carte.
Je ne sais plus si ça fonctionne. Ah, voilà, je crois que ça fonctionne comme
ça. Voilà, bon,
et je ne suis pas trop mauvais. J'ai réussi à trouver directement. Là, j'ai la
carte et en fait,
je peux voir là, je vais zoomer. Je peux voir la tendance des prix. Donc là,
vous voyez 14 euros
et vous vous dites que je suis un gros menteur. Mais attendez, laissez-moi le
truc de m'expliquer.
Prix moyen des 30 jours, etc. Et on voit, voilà, c'est vraiment, c'est presque
un graphique de trading
où vous pouvez voir l'évolution des prix. Et là, en fait, en dessous, on voit
les offres. Donc là,
par exemple, il y a un allemand qui propose une carte Mewtwo à 9 euros. Et ce
qu'on voit tout
de suite, c'est que c'est une carte coréenne. Si j'affiche la photo, voilà,
c'est en coréen.
Je ne lis pas le coréen. Et du coup, là, vous allez avoir déjà des premiers
paramètres qui vont
influencer sur la valeur de votre carte, c'est-à-dire que les cartes coréennes
vont peut-être avoir
moins de valeur. Du coup, je vais devoir filtrer. La langue, premièrement, c'est
langue japonais.
Donc là, je passe en japonais et vous voyez la première carte japonaise,
c'est vraiment exactement la même. Donc là, vous voyez, bon, c'est écrit en
japonais.
Et si je vous montre la mienne, c'est vraiment écrit en japonais aussi. Et par
contre, en fait,
juste pour vous montrer rapidement, ce que j'ai, moi, c'est que j'ai fait grader
la carte par l'entreprise PSA. PSA, c'est une entreprise qui va juger la
valeur de votre,
la qualité de votre carte. Elle va regarder s'il n'y a pas des défauts, etc. Et
elle va attribuer
une note que vous pouvez voir ici. Et du coup, là, j'ai 10. C'est 10 sur 10,
donc c'est une qualité
parfaite. Si je repasse sur Card Market, en fait, normalement, je dois
pouvoir trouver des cartes
indiquées comme PSA 10. Du coup, normalement, c'est dans les commentaires si je
dis pas de bêtises
Dipsun. Je vais descendre rapidement parce que, du coup, il me semble que ça
va. Là, vous voyez,
PSA 7, 27 euros. Ah, voilà. Ah, PSA 10. Ok, donc, j'avais dit 100 euros. Là,
j'ai l'impression
que ça commence plutôt à 60 euros. Ah non, là où carte move, bit in the case.
Donc là, il y a un petit
défaut. Là, 65 euros, 65 euros. Et donc, par exemple, voilà. Là, vous voyez,
c'est exactement la même
carte que j'ai. Du coup, là, on voit que j'avais dit 100 euros. Je me suis
peut-être un peu emballé,
mais c'est plus à 65 euros. Et du coup, en fait, là, ce qui se passe, c'est que
c'est vraiment
une question d'offre et de demande. C'est-à-dire que les gens vont vendre leurs
cartes et ils vont
décider du prix qu'ils vont mettre en ligne. Et après, c'est un peu comme eBay
ou ce genre de
plateforme. C'est s'il y a des personnes qui achètent, il y a des personnes qui
achètent. Par
exemple, là, vous voyez, la personne l'a mis à 400 euros. Bon, la carte risque de
ne pas partir, bien
évidemment. Mais là, on peut voir les évolutions de prix. Donc voilà. Ça, c'est
vraiment pour l'aspect,
vraiment spéculatif. Là, vous pouvez aller sur une plateforme comme Card Market
et essayer de suivre
le prix des cartes pour essayer d'acheter et de revendre des cartes de
particulier à particulier.
Donc bon, après, voilà, je pense que à la limite, moi, ce que je critique plus,
et c'est même le
comportement que j'ai eu, c'est de plus m'intéresser aux cartes seulement pour
cet aspect
spéculatif. Alors que je pense que l'aspect primordial, c'est plus l'aspect
collection et l'aspect artistique.
Et en fait, je pense que ça sera un autre sujet de discussion, mais je pense que
ça touche un peu
plein d'autres choses. C'est un peu comme le luxe. Le luxe, j'ai l'impression
que les
personnes s'intéressent au luxe, pas pour le goût des beaux objets, mais juste
pour ce que ça
représente et pour l'argent que ça représente. Si vous prenez un sac Louis
Vuitton, et là,
je vais donner seulement mon avis, vous avez le droit d'aimer les sacs Louis
Vuitton. Mais je
trouve que les sacs Louis Vuitton avec le motif Louis Vuitton, je trouve ça pas
très beau. Et en
fait, je pense que les gens aiment ça seulement parce que c'est très visible et
on reconnaît tout
de suite que c'est un sac Louis Vuitton. Du coup, on sait tout de suite que
c'est quelque chose qui
coûte cher. Malheureusement, quand il y a de l'argent avec de la spéculation, il
y a forcément
des requins. Mais du coup, voilà, c'est un aspect peut-être complémentaire, mais
c'est un aspect
différent qui peut peut-être un peu entaché, l'aspect initial du jeu qui est
qu'à la base,
on jouait à Pokémon, on essayait de collectionner les 150 Pokémon et que
maintenant, il y a beaucoup
de gens qui s'intéressent à ça seulement parce que ça vaut de l'argent. Je dis
ça,
mais j'ai des cartes et j'aimerais bien qu'elles prennent de la valeur. Si cette
carte demain vaut
10 000 euros, je serais le premier content. Donc voilà, c'est pas noir ou blanc,
je jette la pierre
à personne, mais je trouve intéressant de parler de ce phénomène. J'espère en
tout cas que ce genre
de vidéo vous aura plu. Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à venir sur la chaîne
Twitch directement. Je
pense que je ferai d'autres formats comme ça directement sur Twitch. Là, il y a
Dipsun avec
qui on a parlé parce que c'est mon frère, du coup il m'aide et lui, il
collectionne les cartes Pokémon.
Mais après, si vous avez des idées aussi de discussion, on peut voir ce qu'on
peut
discuter de ce que vous voulez. Donc n'hésitez pas à venir sur le stream, il y
aura le lien dans
ma chaîne et je pense refaire ce genre de vidéo parce qu'avec les échanges avec
le chat,
je trouve ça très intéressant pour l'apprentissage du français. Merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout. Là, on va continuer le stream, on va jouer à un jeu vidéo et je
vous dis à la prochaine.